Grandmothers ravioli.
There's something I was doing for years.
I was doing there,
my cafe balloons and I started them as a
Sunday special,
uh,
just cause it seemed,
you know,
within that context of kind of French
American international kind of flavors
to have something on Sunday that was
kind of comforting.
Um,
are they my grandmother's wherever you
all these.
Exactly.
No,
I mean she never used short ribs in them
and uh,
you know,
didn't use fresh tomato for the sauce.
Uh,
it's kind of like an in quotes,
inspiration type of thing.
Um,
but I'm Italian and Polish and,
uh,
that's uh,
you know,
to good cooking cuisines.
Um,
one doesn't have a lot of vegetables in
it,
the other one does,
but it's,
uh,
you know,
to kind of good cooking cultures,
Italian restaurant.
So I want to keep it in Italian,
in spirit.
You know,
uptown.
When I was the chef at cafe blue,
I had,
uh,
I had some,
my grandmother's parole,
he's on the menu
and they were pretty good.
Uh,
they,
uh,
they got some,
you know,
they got some mentions.
I didn't really promote them or
anything.
They just put them on the menu just
because I wanted to make some,
and they were a little bit fancy.
Um,
it was like three different flavors.
And I made a sauce with the juice from
the Sauerkraut,
homemade Sauerkraut,
and it had like poppy seeds and Julian
apple and stuff like that on it.
So it was kind of like a fancy version
of the progress that we used to buy when
I was a kid at the parochial church,
which was down the street.
It's an interesting little,
uh,
a similar thing,
but the routines,
which are the eye,
the half my town and families from
Friuli and they were a French family
that immigrated from Paris to freely in
the mid 18 hundreds.
Uh,
so my grandmother was half French and,
uh,
she also,
spoke highly of people like the scuff ea
had all these stories,
kind of mixed it in there.
[inaudible].